KIMBERLY GUILFOYLE.
THIS IS THE FIVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FIRING UP THE
NRA CONVENTION IN DALLAS.
>> WE ARE FINALLY ALL PUTTING
AMERICA FIRST.
WE ARE SEEING THE INCREDIBLE
RESULTS.
AS A RESULT, OF OUR MASSIVE TAX
CUT AND EVERYBODY'S BENEFITTING
AND EVERYBODY IS HAPPY AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE VERY CONCERNED.
YOU WATCH HOW WELL HOW WELL WE
DO IN '18.
GET OUT AND VOTE.
AND DON'T BE COMPLACENT.
KANYE WEST MUST HAVE POWER.
I DOUBLED MY AFRICAN-AMERICAN
POLL NUMBERS.
IT WENT FROM 11 TO 22 IN ONE
WEEK.
THANK YOU, KANYE, THANK YOU.
YOU SAW THE RECENT POLL CAME OUT
RAZZUK 51 OR 52.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN WITH BAD
PUBLICITY.
DEMOCRATIC LAW MAKERS VOTED
AGAINST LEGISLATION TO CLOSE
DEADLY IMMIGRATION LOOP HOLES.
HOW ABOUT CATCH AND RELEASE.
WEIGH CAUGHT THEM AND RELEASE
THEM.
BYE-BYE.
WE WILL KEEP VIOLENT CRIMINALS
OUT.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED THERE.
WHAT HE DID TO ONE OF THE FINEST
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND WHAT HE DID TO THE ADMIRAL
IS A DISGRACE.
>> Dana: HE WENT ON TO EXPOUND
ON THE ISSUE MUCH GUN RIGHT AND
BEFORE THE SUPPORTERS AND
THANKED THEM.
>> TRUE AMERICAN PATRIOTS OF THE
NRA WHO DEFEND OUR RIGHTS AND
LIBERTY AND OUR GREAT AMERICAN
FLAG.
YOU HAVE NEVER STOPPED FIGHTING
FOR OUR BELOVED CONSTITUTION.
THEY SAID GOING TO THE NRA
CONVENTION AND SPEAKING IS
CONTROVERSIAL.
IT MAY NOT BE POPULAR.
YOU KNOW WHAT I SAY, BYE-BYE,
GOT TO GET ON THE PLANE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING.
>> Dana: WE'LL TAKE IT AROUND
THE TABLE.
HE WAS HAVING FUN TODAY.
>> Greg: YEAH, LIKE A CLASSIC
ROCK BAND WHO DOES HITS IN FRONT
OF THE LOVING CROWD.
AND LIKE THE WALL IS THE
STAIRWAY TO HEAVEN.
KANYE WAS A NEW SONG AND JOHN
KERRY MATERIAL HE INTRODUCED,
WHICH WAS STELLAR COMEDY ROAST.
WHEN YOU ARE 73, YOU SHOULDN'T
BE RIDING A BIKE AND PERFECT
STUFF.
AND I ALWAYS FIND IT.
THIS TO HIM IS ENTERTAINMENT FOR
HIMSELF AND ENTERTAINMENT FOR
OTHER AND AN ANTIDOTE TO THE
NEWS.
WHEN YOU LISTEN TO THE NEWS, ALL
YOU GET IS THE BAD NEWS, STORMY
STUFF AND COLLUSION ACCUSATIONS.
AND WHAT HE DOES HE TALKS ABOUT
THE JOB NUMBER AND TALKS ABOUT
NORTH KOREA AND THE GOOD NEWS
WHICH IS THE ANTIDOTE TO THE BAD
NEWS AND SO IT IS HEALTHY FOR
HIM AND HIS SUPPORTER AND
HEALTHY FOR PEOPLE WATCHING AT
HOME TO SEE THE OTHER SIDE.
>> Dana: I DON'T KNOW IF THE
OTHER NETWORKS TOOK IT LIVE BUT
WE DID.
THE BULLY PULPIT IS VERY
POWERFUL.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE
A SPEECH IN FRONT OF A BIG
CROWD, IT MEANS MORE THAN
A NEWSCAST.
>> Kimberly: IT WAS A GOOD PLUG
FOR THE BOOK AND THIS IS WHAT
THE GOOD NEWS IS CHANGING THE
DIALOGUE AND NARRATIVE AND SO HE
WILL TAKE CHANGE.
HE'S GOOD WITH THE CAMPAIGN
RALLY AND IN FRONT OF
A RECEPTIVE AUDIENCE AND PICKING
UP WHAT HE'S DROPPING.
HE FEELS AT HOME IN A SITUATION
LIKE THAT AS WELL.
>> Jesse: I WATCHED IN A ROOM
THAT IT MSNBC AND ONLY TIME WITH
UTFETTERED ACCESSES TO
COMMUNICATE HIS MESSAGE.
THERE WERE CUT AWAY AND TIMES
WHEN THE AUDIENCE WAS APPLAUDING
AND HE WOULD STOP SPEAKING FOR
15 OR 20 SECONDS.
AND FOX NEWS WENT TO CUT AWAYS
TO THE AUDIENCE AND SHOWED WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE ROOM.
CNN NO WAY TO SHOW THE AUDIENCE.
GOING INTO 2018.
IT IS IT THE BASE.
AND HE TALKS ABOUT THE
ENTHUSIASM LEVEL.
YOU BETTER GET UP.
>> Dana: THAT IS A GOOD POINT
ABOUT THE MIDTERMS THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY EASY FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY USUALLY LOSE SEATS EVEN
THOUGH HIS APPROVAL WITH
REPUBLICANS IS HIGHEST.
88 OR 90 PERCENT.
THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS TRANSLATE TO
ENTHUSIASM AND GETTING OUT TO
VOTE.
YOU THINK THAT WAS THE PLOY.
>> Juan: IF YOU CONSIDER THE
MID- TERM AND POLL NUMBERS.
THEY HAVE TURNED IN FAVOR OF GUN
CONTROL VERY STRONGLY.
AND AFTER PARKLAND, REMEMBER THE
PRESIDENT WAS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
WE CARRIED HERE ON FOX HAVING
A MEETING AND SAY I THINK WE
NEED STRONGER GUN CONTROL TO YOU
GUYS AND YOU GUYS ARE AFRAID OF
THE NRAN AND FIVE DAYS HE FLIP-
FLOPPED.
NONE THELESS, HE IS TRYING TO
MAKE THE CASE HE IS THE MAN THE
NRA POURED 32 MILLION IN THE
CAMPAIGN AND AFTER HE WAS
ELECTED.
YOU WERE WITH ME AND I WILL
ALWAYS BE WITH YOU.
>> Dana: WERE YOU SURPRISED HE
DIDN'T TALK ABOUT THAT.
HE WAS WILLING TO CHALLENGE THE
NRA, BUT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE PRESIDENT DOES, THAT MAKES
SENSE.
NOW, I UNDERSTAND WHY IT ENERGY
ARMY SCHOOL TEACHERS IS NOT DONE
NATIONALLY.
THAT WOULD BE A CASE BY CASE IN
THE DISTRICT.
>> Greg: THE BLESSING AND
CHALLENGE OF DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS THE CONVERSATIONAL
PRESIDENT.
HE WILL TALK ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THAT UPSETS ME AND B
HAPPENS, WELL, WAIT A SECOND.
HE WENT ON A LONG TEAR OF IF ONE